okay so I just got chica back from the
vet um she's not having a good time
right now
she's very upset with me
she's just generally not having a good
time she's also quite high on
painkillers as far as I'm told she's
just the sweetest puppy but she's not
having a good time Rendon I feel so bad
chica is okay it's all right it's gonna
be okay she's been walking around a lot
with that count on her head but she's
generally okay so you're gonna be okay
you're okay cheeky okay good girl she's
so bad she's so mad at me you guys may
not be easy to tell but I know she's mad
at me
why did you betray me and take me to
that horrible place where the doctors
cut me open it was bad I feel incredibly
bad for chica she uh she keeps moving
about five feet and then stopping
completely and not going anywhere I'm
trying to get her to go outside as
desperately as I can and she's making it
but the progress is slow so chica come
on come on chica you wanna you wanna go
outside you come chica wanna go outside
would you pull people for you give up
you'll be good
dude you popular few of you you puppy
good hey buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
but wait about P papa
oh yeah babby pup she will never trust
me again she will literally over
everything I have ever loved I can't
take credit for that my friend
told me that okay so I've officially
given up on trying her to go outside
because she hasn't moved
so I'm trying now to get her to come up
the stairs to her doggy bed in my room
because that's where she's going to be
most comfortable that's where I can look
after her unfortunately she hasn't moved
from her spot in like 15 minutes
chika little response chika chika chika
be good be good
chika chika you wanna come up steer
chika chika come on Bobby come on Bobby
who you Bobby won't you who's your lucky
lucky lucky lucky lucky be good you
be good when they come on you want
coughs tears Bobby boo
you want to come upstairs chunka bunker
when come upstairs you can want to go up
deer you turn your head a little bit
that's progress
that's what I call progress okay so as
you may be able to see him not on it was
not sure but I had to carry her upstairs
but she is here she kind of conked out
pretty immediately a little bed the poor
girl is gonna be recovering for a while
tomorrow she should pick up a little
more energy
I'm tired myself so I'm probably gonna
go to bed soon even though it's still
daylight out but whatever I didn't get
much sleep last night because we were
filming the five nights at Freddy's
musical night four and five so a lot of
cool stuff coming with that very soon
but poor little girl here she's in for a
rough day but needed to be done
I'm sorry chica okay so I just woke up
I'm checking on chica
and she seems to be in a little better
spirits today a little more PAP but I do
got to give her her pain medication
first thing in the morning today and
then I'm gonna be watching over her most
of the day so if you guys are seeing
this I'm just gonna try to be a good dad
today and take care of her and make sure
that she's doing okay and got everything
that she needs and I'm gonna be making
sure she doesn't rip out her stitches or
anything like that so she can you ready
to go oh you can't climb in my lap with
that thing oh oh she's killing me 50
head and hey chica be good okay he
likes it trying to hold my hand - she'll
lift her POB like weirdly you can't see
oh oh my mom saw but wish chica good
recovery she's trying to hold my hand
she always gets very you know t-rex paws
what's the whole peer appeal so anyway
wish her good luck recovering and she's
gonna need it but she's doing okay
because she's a good bub and this good
bub is gonna last a while so she will
survive just your cookbook say goodbye
to the care alright bye guys see you
tomorrow